hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number we should
have talked about this before we went on
air number
88 right 188 of course um that makes
sense because of the last one being 187.
it does um yes uh I'm Dr Brett Weinstein
you were Dr Heather Hein we are going to
confront some of the uh the emerging
phenomenology of uh things local to
planet Earth
fine phenomenology
and everyone else
yes well yeah phenomenology are is the
it's like the set of related phenomena
to some pattern of focus
okay the phenomenology surrounding you
know the growth of your garden would
involve
soil nutrients it would involve sunlight
it would involve uh systems impinging on
yeah those things that are relevant to
I would say
ology makes it sound like it is a a
careful
scholarly discipline but of course
there's lots of ologies out there that
sound like that and aren't anymore so I
happen to know that the study of
phenomenology is the is a phenomenology
so which is a subset of biology is it
yes uh when we're talking about living
systems sure
all right here we are all right big
progress this is such a big progress I
think we might even be done
uh you mean like finished yeah like
canceled oh gosh that's happened before
well here we are you are watching or
listening to us on any number of
platforms but if you are watching
consider coming over to rumble uh and uh
and joining us there subscribing to the
channel there and if you're watching
live
um even if even if you're not watching
live especially if you're watching live
come join us on locals that's what the
watch party is happening
um we got lots of cool stuff going on
locals lots of advantages to joining us
there we really uh encourage you to do
that and we'll talk more about other
places to find us and reasons to join us
and such at the end of the show
um but for now we're gonna do a q a
after Today's Show and you can ask
questions at darkhorsesmissions.com and
we're just going to talk to you about
our three sponsors at the top of the
hour which are mind Bloom Sundays in
paleo Valley this week so without
further totally with a cameo I totally
forgot to tell you we were on the
mainland yesterday
and um a guy stopped me
uh his name was Chris I believe and he
said he'd been holding on to a line
forever and he was going to deliver it
in person he said that um our influence
in the world was such that if we were a
musical act we would be called relief
band which is of course a sponsor that
we have had from for many uh
a couple years now yeah in any case so
that happened that's a cameo uh a cameo
ad spot for a sponsor that we love and
uh anyway somebody mentioned them on the
street excellent yes there it is trying
to figure out when that might have
happened given that we were together
most of the time oh when was that when
did that happen I had just gotten off
the I will fill in the details for them
I had just gotten off my motorcycle
which I had to take to the mainland to
get the firmware updated by the dealer
who are the only people who could do it
in order that the bike would be able to
go in reverse yep and I was at that
right
um taking our younger son to the
mainland to get it to get his firmware
updated for the school year also known
as his clothing I think that's software
I mean if it's properly made
no no no
if it was hard where it'd be it'd be
scratchy you wouldn't want to wear it
so all right I better close have got to
be software
all right this is not been that
productive there are a bunch of people
out there a lot of them have already
forgotten that it happened but there are
a certain number of people out there
scratching their heads over a firmware
update that requires you to take your
bike to the mainland in order to go in
reverse but you're a motorcycle that's
true yeah yep that was it is all true
and you can now go in reverse apparently
I can now go in reverse you could go in
reverse but now the bike will help
hmm
hey you know we had a cat once
just to beep beep she went in Reverse
yes so she or he
dude
I mean sometimes it's hard to tell I
wonder how many people have a cat and
have the wrong idea of what sex it is
for its entire life and never get
confirmation of the uh reality but you
know in this case that was a sheep that
was a she yeah
exactly all right it's ad time yep
everything start of course I am
uh again with the reading yeah again
with the reading I'll write our first
sponsor this week is mind Bloom mind
Bloom is the leader in at home ketamine
therapy offering a combination of
scientifically robust medicine with
clinically guided support for people
looking to improve their mental health
and well-being
if you or someone you love is struggling
with mental health health issues those
issues May Loom large in your life there
is no one-size-fits-all solution but you
know that you or your loved one need
something that will help achieve a real
and Lasting breakthrough maybe it's time
for you to consider a guided ketamine
Therapy Program from mind Bloom mind
Bloom could be your next and most
successful chapter in improving your
mental health and well-being mind Bloom
connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience to begin take mind
Bloom's online assessment and schedule a
video consultation with a licensed
clinician to determine if mind Bloom is
right for you if approved you'll discuss
your health history and goals for mental
health treatment with your clinician to
tailor your mind Bloom regimen mind
Bloom will send you a kit in the mail
complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience after only four
sessions 89 of Mind Bloom clients
reported improvements in their symptoms
of depression and anxiety
reports one client on their site quote
mind Bloom has enabled me to release the
hold of negative thought patterns in my
life
end quote mind Bloom has guided so many
people into a better chapter of mental
health and well and well-being you
should try it for yourself right now
mind Bloom is offering our listeners 100
off your first six session program when
you sign up at mindbloom.com Darkhorse
and use the code Darkhorse at checkout
go to mindbloom.com
darkhorsepromocode Darkhorse to get a
hundred dollars off your first
succession program today that's m i n d
b l o m.com slash Darkhorse promo code
Darkhorse
our second sponsor this week is Maddie's
all-time favorite Maddie who is lying of
somewhat nondescript behind us there she
is
I'll go off screen so you can see Maddie
there we go
she's not interested at the moment
because she doesn't yet know that we're
talking about Sundays
yeah she doesn't know it by name as you
might not expect her to she does know it
from the sound of the velcro closure on
the back yeah it's Gotta the bag also
has a good closure we never mentioned
that no it's man this is just a great
dog food we love Sundays too because
what dog owner and dog lover doesn't
love a product that is great for their
dog so I'm just I'm I'm gonna just go
back into screen here because the dog's
not helping
um
uh and their dog thinks it's great too
Sundays makes dry dog food when they
approach us about being sponsored we
were dubious Maddie this dog here is a
labrador Labs leap basically anything
what possible difference could uh she
show an interest between her usual
kibble which is a widely available
high-end brand and Sundays well we were
wrong Maddie's Maddie Maddie loves the
food that Sundays makes loves it if we
run out of Sundays and give her her
previous high-end kibble instead she is
disappointed in us although being a lab
she doesn't want to show that no she
doesn't want to show her disappointment
but she knows that we can do better we
can give her some days and we should not
only is Sunday's Maddie's favorite it is
also far better for her than the
standard burnt kibble that comprises
most dried dog food Sundays is the first
and only human grade air dried dog food
air drying combines the best of cooked
and raw approaches like raw air drying
preserves nutrients and tastes better
than high heat methods better than raw
though Sunday's unique air drying
process includes a kill step which kills
pathogens so unlike freeze-dried raw or
frozen raw dog foods there's no food
safety or handling risk with Sundays
combining the nutrition and taste of all
natural human grade foods with the ease
of a zero prep ready date formula
Sundays is an amazing way to feed your
dog there's no fridge no prep no cleanup
no gross wet dog food smells it's a
total pleasure for the human interacting
with it which is a bonus Sundays has no
artificial binder synthetic additives or
general garbage seriously look at the
label all of Sunday's ingredients are
easy to pronounce and healthy for dogs
to eat in a blind taste test Sundays
outperform leading competitors 42-0 and
our own little anecdote Maddie our
Labrador supports that results when I
have a bowl of Sundaes ready for her
it's a whole different level of
enthusiasm from her usual enthusiasm for
food she bounces and Spins and leaps of
anticipation do you want to make your
dog happy with their diet and keep her
healthy try Sundays we've got a special
deal for our listeners receive 35 off
your first order go to sundays4dogs.com
Darkhorse or use code Darkhorse at
checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash Darkhorse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you are feeding
your dog it's pretty pretty good
to um wrote Larry David
and you would know I would know I'm one
of you who would know but I do know yeah
and uh yeah it's pretty pretty good in a
pinch it would work as well mix for
humans
and if you didn't tell them they'd be
none the wiser they probably would
I don't think so no really okay I had a
couple M M's
oh then they I don't know that Eminem's
is the right matching I think yeah
anymore in the uh
main reasons you'd get away with
something over a nut word would be
onward yes our final sponsor this week
is Paleo Valley paleo Valley makes a
huge range of products we have extolled
the virtues of their beef sticks on air
before and everything we tried from them
has been terrific today we want to tell
you about their superfood golden milk
golden milk is also known as turmeric
milk it's delicious nutritious hot drink
rich in turmeric usually made in the
base of either milk or coconut milk
if you are the sort of person who goes
to fancy coffee bars
um especially anywhere on the coast but
I assume many places where there's where
we have an espresso bar you probably
have seen turmeric milk on the menu and
if you've tried it
um probably you've really enjoyed it
it's quite delicious paleo Valley makes
a version that makes it easy for you to
make at home and it's fantastic
turmeric is a flowering plant in the
ginger family and it grows across much
of tropical Asia Joseph with ginger the
rhizome of turmeric has been used
culinarily and medicineally across
cultures for a very long time modern
research backs up ancient traditions and
we now know that turmeric is an
antioxidant and anti-inflammatory among
many other beneficial mechanisms of
action
a particularly delicious way to get
turmeric in your diet is through golden
Milk enter paleo Valley's superfood
golden milk paleo Valley's delicious
product has turmeric of course but also
Ginger cinnamon black pepper which
apparently is useful in helping the body
uptake turmeric
coconut milk powder and a little bit of
monk fruit to add sweetness and several
species of mushrooms also lion's mane
reishi shiitake and cordyceps it's
gluten-free grain free soy free non-GMO
and it's delicious paleo Valley does not
cut Corners they Source only the highest
quality ingredients and they use whole
ingredients unlike many competitor
products their superfood golden milk has
whole turmeric not just curcumin a
component of turmeric and whole
certified organic mushrooms not just the
Mycelia golden milk is understood to
help reduce inflammation enhance
cognitive function support immune
function improve digestion and increase
endurance
I'm not sure for what but endurance yeah
paleo Valley is passionate not only
about human health but environmental
restoration and Animal Welfare as well
and they're a family-owned company
tripelio Valley superfood golden milk
today you'll be so glad that you did
head over to paleovalley.com that's
p-a-l-e-o-v-a-l-l-e-y.com Darkhorse for
15 off your first order
fantastic fantastic I do love tumor
turmeric
turmeric fine ingredient it tastes great
yeah it does indeed uh you want to be
careful about getting out of your
clothes yes well unless you get it all
over your clothes very evenly or you're
already Welling wearling
already wearing turmeric colored colored
clothes this is not going to be easy
today no it's it's gonna be uh tripping
over words but all right so be it
um we both want to talk about some stuff
going on in sort of medicine land but
not the usual not the usual yeah you
want to start sure why not yeah so I
wanted to give an update and in light of
that update uh paint a certain picture
from a a bit that we covered
geez would be several months ago at this
point it would be I think back in June
in fact we can figure out almost exactly
when it was
based on the publication yeah it was in
June of 2023. we covered the publication
of a paper uh Zach you want to show the
paper
uh the paper's title is familial clonal
hematopoiesis in Long telomere syndrome
by DuBois and many other authors to boy
at all and we covered this paper because
although it is independently fascinating
and it's even more fascinating to us in
light of the fact that it
is it matches the prediction of the
telomere hypothesis that I published
with Debbie cesic back in 2002 that is a
paper that many who listen to the
podcast will know a whole bunch about it
is a paper that argued that the
evolutionary theory of senescence and I
used the word theory correctly there
this has now been borne out by many
empirical results but the evolutionary
theory of senescence is a match for many
of the mechanistic discoveries that have
been made in gerontology in the study of
cancer and
um and elsewhere in biology of late and
my point at the time that we covered it
before was that actually this
paper completed the puzzle that it shows
that long telomeres are associated with
the
um the inheritance of a predisposition
to malignant neoplasms that is cancers
which is an exact match for the
hypothesis that I published with Debbie
cesic
and that is a match for the fact which
has been known now for a couple decades
that short telomeres are associated with
progeria syndromes Progeria syndromes
being accelerated aging syndromes and
the hypothesis that we've got little
boys look like old men
that is Hutchinson Guilford Progeria
which is the most extreme of the
Progeria syndromes uh and it is almost
always males and in those cases these
kids have
every pathology normally associated with
aging saved two and the two are they
don't get cognitive decline they have
the minds of children everybody's sharp
and they don't get cancer so anyway that
is all a kind of interesting background
but
the point of this paper was made in
isolation from most of that context the
point of this new paper the point of
this newspaper yeah boy at all did not
mention any of the evolutionary context
that creates this rather complete
picture and so I thought it oh go ahead
it just it is another example of
something we've talked about repeatedly
which is to say the
um the the exclusive rise of empiricism
over theory in much of what is passing
for science if all you do is you go out
and look for things to test without
considering in advance what might be
true and why and have a careful
hypothesis going in and consider why
things might be true at the systemic
level you end up frankly
with you know at best you end up with
papers like this which appear to be work
that is well done at a technical level
but which is unframed in terms of in in
terms of any context in which it could
be interpreted which means you derive a
small fraction of the power that you
would get from the work so the work cost
whatever it costs to do in terms of the
time the people who did it the grants
that went into it the laboratory space
all of the materials that's some cost
and then the question is what did you
get what's the return on investment well
the return on investment goes through
the roof if you place these things
properly in their theoretical context
especially if you're dealing with a
broad powerful Theory rather than a
narrow and mundane one so in any case in
light of this I thought the right thing
to do the right thing to do in normal by
the normal academic rules and the right
thing to do logically speaking was to
submit a letter to the New England
Journal of Medicine calling their
attention to the theoretical context
that had been missed
now my feeling was just once again the
New England Journal of Medicine being
the publication being the journal where
this paper was published where this
paper was published and I forgot to
mention the New England Journal of
Medicine when they published uh the
familial hematopoiesis paper by Dubois
at all also published an a editorial on
it describing the importance of this
paper so the reason that that matters is
that the New England Journal of Medicine
thought this a significant enough piece
of work that they actually did a
commentary on what it meant in the same
issue but still missing The evolutionary
context still missing The evolutionary
context so if you think about this
I as a person from an adjacent field
evolutionary biology who knows the
evolutionary context providing that
context to the New England Journal of
Medicine this should be a win for
everybody I get to point out the context
the authors of the paper get to have
that context placed historically around
their paper which increases the
importance of the paper the New England
Journal of Medicine gets to take a
Victory lap because the paper it
published is even more important than it
had realized at first it's its wins
across the board
so I did submit a letter
I submitted a letter and letters are a a
form of academic publication they are
very tightly regulated in terms of
length and format you are in this case
allowed only five references and uh it
had a very short word limit so I wrote
my letter and showed to a number of
people and then I submitted it and I
wanted to read that letter so people can
get a sense for what the New England
Journal of Medicine was looking at uh
yeah I wanted to show it
I said in this letter
science produces explanatory theories
when predictive hypotheses withstand
rigorous tests in showing that long
telomeres promote life-shortening
pathologies including cancer de boy at
all have made an important Discovery
even more significant because it matches
predictions of the reserve capacity
hypothesis which cesic and I elucidated
in 2002. the boy at all were apparently
unaware they had tested our model and in
so doing completed a classic series of
insights beginning with metawar in 1952
and Williams in 1957.
with their contribution we now have a
unified mechanistic and darwinian
explanation for why we grow old the
force of natural selection decreases
with age creating a trade-off between
longevity and youthful vigor
invertebrates this trade-off manifests
as a telomere mediated balance between
tumor suppression and tissue repair
runaway somatic cell lines are arrested
at their hayflake limits but the aging
body is condemned to degrade beginning
at reproductive maturity due to the
incomplete and increasingly chaotic
replacement of lost cells
so that's the letter
and I recently got word that the New
England Journal of Medicine wasn't
interested in it they did not send it
out for review they uh
declared it dead at the editorial stage
and I want to
now show you the note that they sent me
they said
Dear Mr Weinstein I am sorry that we
will not be able to publish your recent
letter to the editor regarding the
armanios article of 29th June 2023 the
space available for correspondence is
very limited and we may use our judgment
to present a representative selection of
material received many worthwhile
Communications must be declined for lack
of space thank you for your interest in
the journal sincerely Etc
all right
that is it was armanios the final author
uh I believe so
um the
the
note that they sent is pure boilerplate
and it is meant to read as pure
boilerplate the idea is you didn't even
rise to the level of our interest this
was not worth a note that was uh penned
specifically
um which is if you think about it rather
odd I sent them a note which would take
very little space to
um to publish that increase the power of
what they had already published and
commented on and they were not
interested in the historical context and
we can speculate about why that is but I
thought in light of the fact that they
were not interested in publishing this
that I would cover what the story that
is now complete looks like because
really it's an amazing moment that we
can now say we're not speculating it's
not there is a hypothesis that says we
now have substantial empirical
demonstration that illustrates that this
long pattern of of hypothesis and
Discovery starting in 1952
is actually correct and it gives us a
simple answer to the question why do we
grow feeble and inefficient with age
which is a deep question that virtually
every human being Ponders
all right so to lay this out what
um what Peter meadowwar said in 1952 he
actually this is an interesting piece of
History he delivered a talk it was not
even a paper and it wasn't a paper in
the sense of a talk delivered at a
conference either he delivered a public
speech
that was titled an unsolved problem in
biology
now Peter medowar was a British
biologist he ultimately won a Nobel
Prize for his work on immunological
graft rejection he's the guy who
discovered why it is that if we take an
organ from somebody who's a blood type
match and we we install it in another
person it is very likely to be rejected
by the body and why you need a very
close match of the major hista
compatibility complex to get a graph not
to be rejected but anyway he delivered a
public talk called an unsolved problem
in biology
which is now largely lost to history I
had to work fairly hard to dig up a copy
of it but in any case he he laid out a
case for why it is that aging or
senescence should evolve in his case
this is back in 1952 involved a thought
experiment which was about a a
some number of test tubes that arrived
at a laboratory
um you know like a thousand test tubes
arrived in a package at a laboratory and
then the question is how many of those
test tubes would still be around a year
in five years in a decade in 20 years in
and you can imagine that these test
tubes which are no worse on their
fifth year in service or their tenth
year in service than they were when they
were first delivered would still
diminish in number over time that you
could graph how many test tubes would be
left at a x number of years out and that
there would be a number of years out at
which no test tubes would be left just
because there is some rate of breakage
of test tubes or loss of test tubes
that would eventually get rid of all of
them and so what metal are in this
public talk where his real point was not
about senescence his real point was
here's how you address a problem we
haven't solved
so this was just a demonstration of how
logic Works in biology and in so doing
he solved an important piece of the
puzzle so what he said was
if you take an object that does not
degrade with a like test tubes and you
look at the rate of attrition what you
discover is that you get fewer and fewer
of them left independent of aging and
then he reasoned that were there then
characteristics of test tubes that
affected them badly at some point in the
future that those impacts the farther in
the future they existed would be less
and less significant because fewer and
fewer test tubes would be around to
experience them so by less significant
you mean under less selective pressure
right because there are fewer test tubes
around to experience them right so for
example let's say you had a condition in
which a test tube would spontaneously
disintegrate 300 years after it was
minted well virtually no test tube would
ever disintegrate by this mechanism
because virtually no test tube makes it
300 years so the point is what's the
cost of such a pathology it's virtually
zero
so his point was selection C's late life
less clearly than it sees early life and
therefore
you ought to get pathologies very late
in life that are too far removed from
selection's ability to do anything about
them to for selection to fix it and on
the one hand I will argue that this
is sufficient that this single point of
matters is sufficient to explain
senescence
but it does not work for the senescence
that we see
because the fact is selection we begin
to degrade very early in life and we
actually begin to degrade upon reaching
reproductive maturity and so that's too
early for the weakness of selection to
explain the process so 1952 Peter
medowar lays out his uh case for
selection getting weaker the deeper into
the lifespan one gets it is sufficient
to explain some pattern of senescence
but it is not sufficient to explain the
pattern of senescence that we actually
see in animals so it isn't very many
years 1952 Peter medowar lays that out
George Williams who we knew we never met
matawar but we knew George Williams
um puts the second piece of The
evolutionary puzzle together and over in
laboratory space when these guys are
mentioned they're very often mentioned
as if they said the same thing which
they didn't Williams built on matawar
and what he said was that trade-offs
were at the heart of this process
because his point and we didn't know
that much about the genome back when
William said this in 1957 so he was
insightful not only he was insightful
enough that what he said stood up even
though his mechanistic understanding was
crude what he said was genes will tend
to do more than one thing
that the weakness of selection for late
life processes comes into play when you
have a gene that does something good for
you early in life at some cost late in
life because the early life benefit
counts more than the late night life
harm for the reasons that medowar laid
out and so what he said is there would
be a balance between youthful vigor and
Longevity and that selection would have
to deal with these things based on
important characteristics like how much
risk were you at because according to
medowar the more risk you are at from
things that have nothing to do with how
old you are
the less likely you are to make it to an
advanced age at which you would
experience some pathology so if you're
if you're a mouse living in an
environment in which there are lots of
Raptors and you're not likely to make it
five years senescence or no because a
raptor is likely to pick you off and the
benefits of being a particularly
effective Mouse when you're young far
outweigh the ability to live to an
advanced stage which you're not going to
get to anyway so
yeah go ahead I'm just a just to restate
um some of what you've already said uh
the observation that genes will tend to
do more than one thing is called
plyotropy and uh generally speaking
um certainly in till Williams but I
think since and almost almost
universally
um it is understood that like yes a gene
may do X and Y and isn't that
interesting and maybe we would prefer X
to Y and we don't necessarily want to
um encourage both things by you know
promoting the expression of of that Gene
but it's plyotropic and so what are you
going to do and so his observation uh
that early life affects from a gene that
also have late life effects which are
negative
is uh it has a unique name associated
with that kind of plyotropy which is
antagonistic Plateau antagonistic plate
trip yep that's just to fill in some of
the vocabulary no and please do that
because this will be far clearer if we
if we do it that way
okay so Williams lays out this
theoretical model it has lots of
interesting implications which are
proven by biologists field biologists
who studied populations of creatures
they showed that similar creatures for
example ostad a former lion tamer showed
that possums living on islands where
their predators are greatly reduced in
number have greater longevity when taken
into the lab so he showed that Williams
Williams intuition about creatures that
live in safer environments having their
longevity extended by selection
um was true also laid out in Williams
paper was the fact that creatures that
have a defense against predation would
tend to outlive similar creatures that
don't so for example uh if you compare
rodents to birds flighted birds of a
similar size size tends to correlate
with longevity the bigger an animal you
are the longer you tend to live but
things that are flighted if we're
actually better species between species
so if you compare for example
screws to bats screws and bats are not
very distantly related but bats have
picked up flight and that means that
they can fly away from danger in a way
that a shrew can't the bats are
disproportionately long-lived and some
are very shockingly long-lived there are
small bats who've been recovered after
three decades in the wild that's a kind
of longevity that would be unheard of in
something like a shrew
so anyway there are lots of things about
Williams paper that clearly are borne
out by indirect evidence but the odd
thing about his paper he lays out this
mechanism and as Heather points out the
prediction of this paper is that the
genome should be full of genes that do
something good for you early in life at
some late life cost and at the point
that I started working on this in the
very late 90s not a single such Gene had
ever been found we knew that the effect
that Williams had described was real
because we could see it in the pattern
of Aging but the genes weren't we they
weren't in evidence anywhere we could
see them so that was a head scratcher
and that is where you know if you
some of you will know that my
dissertation was on trade-offs that's
the thing that I have chosen to
specialize on and that my belief is that
trade-offs actually allow us to answer
lots of questions that we can't answer
otherwise this is where I got the idea I
looked at Williams elegant paper and I
said oh this is a very powerful style of
thinking and it doesn't stop with
senescence so I sort of picked up what
he had done and did some new stuff with
it but all right so we've got Williams
says selection decreases with age
because lots of creatures just for
reasons of accidents and disease and
whatever you don't get to an advanced
stage and therefore you don't suffer as
much from things that happen late in
life Williams says
sorry yes yes meta War said that first
thing William says it actually has to be
trade-offs which explains why we start
aging or we start so nesting so
um early in life Williams also said some
other really interesting things like
that senescence was a self exacerbating
problem
that once the selection decides to allow
you to grow more feeble with age it
makes the likelihood of you getting
picked off by a predator or getting
felled by a disease worse which means
the likelihood of you getting to an
advanced age gets worse and so the point
is once you start finessing the bias
towards early life grows it's a positive
feedback which is a pretty neat
mechanism to find there
unfortunate but neat
yeah unfortunate beneath
um and you know we can talk about
creatures that don't have the
prerequisites for this pattern we'll do
that another day but
um it's not that this is the only way to
exist is to be a creature and to grow
feeble and inefficient with age there
are other ways to structure a creature
and in fact if you don't have a
segregated germline the whole picture is
different that means if you don't have
separate cells that make gametes yeah so
you could be a cedar and this won't
happen to you yes and you know depending
upon what you're doing it might be as
good a deal Mobility isn't as good
Mobility isn't as good flammability is
higher yeah it's not it's not good but
um trade-offs everywhere
I'm not sure that as well I'll have to
think of it uh off camera but okay so
Williams delivers this update to matawar
in 1957. we all know it's true or
decades after because it's been
demonstrated indirectly the genes that
he suggested would be found were never
found that was weird which I thought was
like huh
what are we doing wrong and now we get
to where the laboratory folks start to
make insights and the the key one early
here is a guy named Lenny hayflick Lenny
hayflick is still around Lenny hayflick
um
showed that the long-standing belief of
laboratory biologists that cells would
go on dividing forever if you gave them
the right conditions was not true for
somatic cells from vertebrates like us
you showed that if you give cells I
think you use chicken cells if you give
Chicken cells
um you know
a nice habitat uh
you know decorations on the walls we
give them all the stuff that a cell
culture could want that those cells go
on dividing for some time and then they
just stop though they are evidently
healthy
so that wasn't understood why that
happened but despite the decorations
just despite despite the hospitable
habitat the they just stopped dividing
and so anyway he called this the
hayflick limit
hey flick limits are known to differ
between did you call it that or was it
called I think it was called that I
don't know yeah I don't it's not the
kind of guy who would have named it that
but but anyway
so that's an interesting result and
obviously it has a potential implication
here because cell division is necessary
for defense of the body repair
maintenance all of those things and the
fact that cells won't keep doing it
um obviously could be related to why
we've failed to repair ourselves so that
ultimately we die from the collapse of
one organ or another
um now he did that before
telomeres and telomerase were understood
telomeres are these repetitive sequences
at the ends of chromosomes
they don't code for proteins they're not
genes in that sense they are genetic
material but they are not genes they
don't produce the code is meaningless
it's just a simple repeated sequence but
it produces a cap on the ends of
chromosomes which is often described as
protecting the ends of chromosomes from
the repair Machinery that looks for
Frayed Ends and fixes them
they exist in a loop actually where the
DNA comes back and inserts one of the
two strands inserts into one of the
double-stranded places so you get this
thing called a d loop and that d-loop
shrinks every time a cell divides under
normal circumstances every time a human
cell divides it loses a little bit of
telomere which is often described as
you know the incomplete replication of
the chromosome and I think of it as like
a train that can't reach the very end of
the track at the station because there's
a bumper there right there's a bumper
and so the train Wheels
yeah yeah a zipper any one of these
things where something at the very end
of the line prevents the replication
enzymes from seeing the very end of the
chromosome now it's not a fatal
condition biology has since since our
yeast like ancestors
have the ability to add more telomere so
it could just swap in some extra
telomere for the part at the end of the
line that I can't see but it doesn't
under normal circumstances it allows the
telomere to grow shorter with each cell
division and that
makes uh that opens the question of
whether or not the shortening of
telomeres underlies hayflix limit the
limit where cells refuse to divide
anymore whether that limit underlies the
senescence of the body that we fail to
maintain and repair ourselves because
our cells won't divide
so anyway that was an open question is
that is that the mechanism of the
hayflick limit we now know that it is
um
and I should say Carol Grider and
Elizabeth Blackburn elucidated the
nature of the telomerase enzyme a very
interesting enzyme that allows telomere
to be added either in a a reproductive
part of the process in in the production
of gametes or in cells where a half foot
limit is not tolerated this enzyme which
is mostly protein is all enzymes are
which has an RNA template built into it
it's a very special enzyme actually can
add telomere DNA to
to the ends of chromosomes
okay
um that's a lot of background and the
thing that's
put me on the trail here
I knew all of the hey flick limit stuff
the possibility that telomeres were
involved but I heard a lecture by a
student in a cancer lab in which he
reported that cancers were effectively
all known to have an active version of
the enzyme telomerase where normal
somatic cells the cells of the body not
the germ line
have their telomerase enzymes shut off
they're not present
and so he was describing the excitement
over in the world of people studying
cancer that maybe this enzyme which is
active in all cancers all we've got to
do is turn it off we've cured cancer
and I knew that folks over in the world
of gerontology were interested in
turning on the very same enzyme because
it potentially could revive these cell
lines that refused to divide and halt
the aging process and so you got two
groups of laboratory scientists
who both think they're going to cure one
of the major causes of death for people
but they want to do exactly the inverse
thing and they weren't talking to each
other and I looked at this and I said
huh
Williams I know Williams has said that
you're going to have genes that do
something very good for you early in
life at some cost late in life and he
called this antagonistic pleiotropian
that that was going to be the underlying
explanation for senescence and I said
well maybe the problem is the word Gene
maybe it's not a gene maybe it's a
mechanism that does this which would
have all of the same theoretical
consequences that Williams laid out but
it's not a gene in the sense it doesn't
code for protein
okay so that allowed me and Deborah
sizek to put together a model in which
we showed all of the evidence that would
link these things together the
theoretical explanation hayflix
laboratory Insight
um the what little was known about
Progeria syndromes at the time and we
put together this paper actually maybe
Heather you should show it if you can
show your screen
I can do it
not showing up
okay well while Zach is working on that
puzzle the paper was called The Reserve
capacity hypothesis evolutionary origins
and modern implications of the trade-off
between tumor suppression and tissue
repair all right we should be able to
show it now
no I think so
give it a second all right we're giving
it a second probably shouldn't
experimental gerontology in 2002.
published an experimental gerontology in
2002 and there it is on your screen
um
okay
so this paper laid out a bunch of
the framework I wonder if we should read
the abstract what do you think perhaps
um maybe you'll do better okay given
where it is
again the abstract of Brett and wczek's
2002 paper published an experimental
gerontology in 2002. I already said
already said antagonistic plyotropy The
evolutionary theory of senescence posits
that age-related somatic decline is the
inevitable late life byproduct of
adaptations that increase Fitness and
early life
that concept coupled with recent
findings in oncology and gerontology
provides the foundation for an
integrative theory of vertebrate
senescence that reconciles aspects of
the accumulated damage metabolic rate
and oxidative stress models
we hypothesized that one invertebrates a
telomeric Fail-Safe inhibits tumor
formation by limiting cellular
proliferation
two the same system results in the
Progressive degradation of tissue
function with age
three again these are the distinct
hypotheses of Brett and Debbie in this
paper three these patterns are
manifestations of an evolved
antagonistic plyotropy in which
extrinsic causes of mortality favor a
species optimal balance between tumor
suppression and tissue repair
four with that trade-off as a
fundamental constraint selection adjusts
telomere lengths longer telomeres
increasing the capacity for repair
shorter telomeres increasing tumor
resistance
five in environments were extrinsically
induced mortality Is frequent selection
against senescence is comparatively weak
as few individuals live long enough to
suffer a substantial phenotypic decline
the weaker the selection against
senescence the further the optimal
balance point moves towards shorter
telomeres and increased tumor
suppression the stronger the selection
against senescence the farther the
optimal balance point moves toward
longer telomeres increasing the capacity
of tissue repair slowing senescence and
elevating tumor risks
six in hetero Paris organisms that is
organisms that expect to have multiple
reproductive events in their lifetime in
heteroparis organisms selection tends to
coordinate rates of senescence between
tissues such that no one organ generally
limits lifespan
a subsidiary hypothesis argues that
senescent decline is the combined effect
of one
uncompensated cellular attrition and to
increasing histological entropy
entropy increases due to a loss of the
intra tissue positional information that
normally oops that normally regulates
sulfate and function informational loss
is subject to positive feedback
producing the ever accelerating pattern
of senescence characteristic of
heteroparus vertebrates
though telomere erosion begins early in
development the onset the onset of
senescence should on average be deferred
to the species typical age of first
reproduction
the balance point at which selection on
this trade-off should allow exhaustion
of replicative capacity to overtake some
cell lines
we observe the captive rodent breeding
protocols designed to increase
reproductive output simultaneously exert
strong selection against reproductive
senescence and virtually eliminate
selection that would otherwise favor
tumor suppression
this appears to have greatly elongated
the telomeres of laboratory mice with
their telomeric Fail-Safe effectively
disabled these animals are unreliable
models of normal senescence and tumor
formation
safety tests employing these animals
likely overestimate cancer risks and
underestimate tissue damage and
consequent accelerated senescence
that just that last sentence safety test
is a reference to
drug safety testing yep drug safety
testing why are drug safety tests
constantly failing to find the damage
that these drugs will do here it is in
this paper in 2002. right so this would
account for patterns exactly like we saw
with things like biox fenfen zeldane
erythromycin where you think a drug is
safe and then it turns out to do damage
and the Damage that we notice is heart
damage now you will find this pattern
familiar why heart damage
it's presumably because the heart has a
very low capacity to repair and its
failure is utterly conspicuous so when
young people die from heart failure we
notice so it's not that it does heart
failure we predict that all of these
things do body wide uh damage
but we notice it in the heart and so we
come to think of it as as heart failure
all right so yeah it's it's not that it
doesn't do heart damage it's that we can
more easily see the heart damages so
that is what it is that is what gets
recorded right damage uh the damage that
will kill you in your heart might be
um
unnoticeable if it was done in your
liver where you have a tremendous amount
of capacity to replace damaged tissue
right okay so what we have here
oh no I want to note one thing there is
a piece of this I very much regret how
we named it in this article because the
world had not yet with the biological
world had not yet woken up to the uh the
full importance of the molecular
epigenetic findings that were coming to
light and so what we call histological
entropy should have been called
epigenetic entropy
I believe that this is a very important
fact we predict this and I believe we
are correct about it in this paper that
the
um degradation of the body is in part
about the fact that the body is very
well organized when it is Young at the
at the end of uh maturation it is very
well organized and then a derangement
occurs that isn't the same entropy that
we talk about physically what it is is a
loss of information about what cell
belongs where so the tissues become less
well organized and less effective at
doing all the things that they do but so
it's both like you you know that I think
I think the term histological entropy is
is is brilliant I think it's excellent
and your epigenetic entropy
May better Define the causal thing
that's going on but it manifests like
every every human who ages experiences
this histological entropy where you know
we end up with with color with spots
where we didn't have them before with um
you know less things that were you know
beautiful and clean are no longer as
beautiful hairs out of place right so
that is that that manifestation of uh
perhaps the epigenetic entropy inside is
a for is a kind of histological right
the reason I regret it is not that
there's anything wrong with the term I
think it's a perfectly you know in a
world in which people didn't have biases
it would be a fine a fine descriptor the
problem is it's because we didn't use
the term epigenetic people assume that
this is yet another version of entropy
overtakes the body which is in some
sense not false but it is not a simple
entropy that overtakes the body it is
entropy that overtakes the body because
of hayflick limits which are built
around telomeres Etc in any case I
believe that this is
a topic on which David Sinclair has been
very active he is
in many ways all about the loss of
information but he doesn't cite this
work and I don't know why that is but it
may be because the term did not bring it
into the right Circle I don't and
presumably many of our audience do not
know who you're talking uh David
Sinclair is a senescence researcher he's
also been a Joe Rogan guest which is
probably where people will know him from
um but anyway histological entropy I
believe is an important subsidiary
hypothesis here that will ultimately be
borne out if anybody ever notices that
it was proposed in this paper
but uh leave that be that as it may
I think the important
um the important point is that it took
the generations of biologists to figure
out why we Sines this is a question that
occurs to every biologist and certainly
every biologist since Darwin has
wondered about it in evolutionary terms
is it a failure of evolution is it a
product of evolution there are lots of
bad hypotheses like oh we age so we
don't you know the old don't out compete
The Young and the pursuit of food
there's lots of nonsense in this realm
and the ability to now tell a complete
story and mind you I do fault the
laboratory scientists for not
thinking deeply about the evolutionary
side of the puzzle but I also Fought The
evolutionary folks for not typically
wanting to get too deeply into mechanism
the thing that I think uh Debbie cesic
and I did write was we said look this is
neither a mechanistic question nor an
evolutionary question it is inherently
both as all questions will be
and the ability now to tell a story that
doesn't shortchange one side you tell
just a mechanismistic story of you know
telomeres and hayflick limits and uh but
it also tells a story about creatures
living in environments where extrinsic
causes of mortality are either high in
which case senescence will be profound
or low in which case it will be delayed
right that is a much richer story and it
wasn't something that anybody could do
alone it literally goes back to 1952 and
a beautifully named talk by Peter
medowar in which he tried to show people
how you solve a problem in biology right
what's the answer well you start here
and then it takes Decades of various
people's work to actually complete that
story and so I just want to end here by
reading again the end of the letter
which the New England Journal of
Medicine did not want to publish
not of a sufficient interest I would
think right not of sufficient interest
right it says
um with their contribution that is the
boy at all we now have a unified
mechanistic and darwinian explanation
for why we grow old the force of natural
selection decreases with Aid creating a
trade-off between longevity and youthful
vigor invertebrates this trade-off
manifests as a telomere mediated balance
between tumor suppression and tissue
repair runaway somatic cell lines are
arrested at their hayflick limits that
is cancers but the aging body is
condemned to degrade beginning at
reproductive maturity due to the
incomplete and increasingly chaotic
replacement of lost cells that is now a
one paragraph description of why vertigo
vertebrates grow feeble with age and
it's very elegant and it took you know
what 70 years
um that's a pretty interesting story and
shame on the New England Journal of
Medicine for not being interested in
telling it either not being imaginative
enough to understand it or being so
petty about wanting to be territorial
here that they didn't even want to do
the authors of the boy at all's paper
the service of putting their work in
proper historical context
for shame for shame
well maybe the American Medical
Association is doing better
let's hope so
turns out not well
let's talk about uterine transplants for
a bit
wow yeah okay uterine transplants
well there are some number of uh baby
girls born without uteruses
and uh there are of course many
high-tech and newfangled ways of uh
helping people with uh reduced fertility
uh get fertility of course they're
they're ancient ways of dealing with
this adoption is not limited to humans
it is it is found in other species as
well but uh you know everyone will be
familiar with interventions like IVF and
such and
um
you know we know people who have
benefited from such interventions and
they are you know they do raise uh
ethical questions but uh but it's it is
not you know it has become somewhat
common in some milieus uh for to be
understood that some number of people in
part because uh uh you know upper middle
class educated people are often waiting
a fairly long time uh to start families
uh that there will be assistance uh in
in having kids and
um being you know utterly without a
uterus uh is of course a rather giant
barrier uh and it seems like it might be
too much of a barrier but as it turns
out there have been some
um
some successful attempts to do uterine
transplants in women it's very new it's
mostly unsuccessful it requires a lot of
other systems to be functional question
yes
um a question you may not know the
answer to but successful uterine
transplants does that mean
that transplanted uteruses
I don't know that that's how you
pluralize that but let's just say it is
the uteri but I don't know I would think
it would be uterine but um
neither you nor I know if it's uteri no
no we don't no we don't um is there at
least one case I will be surprised if
there is in which a transplanted uterus
without
surgical intervention resulted in a
healthy vaginal birth of a child what do
you mean by surgical intervention well
obviously the entire thing is rather
surgical right but I will be less
impressed
uh if a cesarean section is necessary
yeah uh to birth that seems much more
likely let's um
let me read to you a bit from this paper
called the history behind successful
uterine transplantation in humans okay
published an article called uh I don't
know what jbra stands for here but
assisted reproduction in 2017 you can
show my screen here
um
by a bunch of researchers in Mexico and
Europe excuse me from the abstract
25 utx uterine transplant procedures
have been performed in humans this is as
a publication of 2017. the first two
cases were unsuccessful but established
the need for rigorous research to
improve success rates as a result of a
controlled clinical study under a
strictly designed research protocol nine
subsequent uterine transplant procedures
have resulted in six healthy live births
the first of them in 2014.
further failed uterine transplant
procedures have been performed in China
Czech Republic Brazil Germany and the
United States most of which used living
donors albeit still an experimental
procedure uh urine transplant is the
first potential alternative for the
treatment of absolute absolute uterine
Factor infertility which is to say just
not having them mostly okay so let me
read just a little bit from the
introduction here
the clinical field of tissue
transplantation now includes uterine
transplants
it has its peculiarities however it is a
transitory procedure that does not
necessarily save a life in danger which
we normally think of with regard to
transplants right but instead improves
quality of life and offers women
anatomically or functionally unable to
Bear children the possibility of
becoming mothers and giving birth to
healthy infants
hysterectomy is indicated after parity
mainly to avoid the risks secondary to
long-term immunosuppression that is
critical right okay so I'm shocked that
this works at all and ever
uh there have apparently been some
successes and I assume it's C-section
but I don't remember I don't remember I
didn't look carefully right
um but it's not permanent you don't get
a uterus and then live with that uterus
for your entire life
um the point is to be able to bring a
baby to term in your own body and to
avoid things like um donors surrogacy
which have a whole other set of um of
ethical problems associated with them
um right and and just and psychological
problems
um but then after a successful birth the
idea is to have that uterus removed so
that you don't have to continue to be on
immunosuppressive drugs and um and such
and so just one more uh thing from the
from the same from the introduction oh
this is just the same thing once parity
has been achieved that is to say once a
birth has successfully happened from a
gestation that occurred in that uterus
the uterus is surgically removed to
allow the suspension of
immunosuppressants thus minimizing
long-term side of effects
so fascinating yeah
um can I just have my screen back come
on a couple of things one very
interesting tie-in with Peter Medawar
because it is the rejection of even a
well-matched uterus which causes the
leaving of the newly installed uterus in
place
uh too costly to contemplate yeah
nowhere in this so far have I heard
anybody so if you put in a uterus and
you have to use immunosuppressive drugs
to reduce the likelihood of graft
rejection
the baby is going to live in that uterus
until in in the body of a woman who is
taking immunosuppressant drugs right
what is the effect of that that is an
obvious question absolutely and
absolutely I think just to put this in
proper context this is another case
where
the terminology
leads you to the wrong model just as we
have vaccines that aren't vaccines yes
they look a lot like vaccines they're
administered like a vaccine but actually
they turn your cells into a vaccine in
the case of an mRNA
so-called vaccine here you've got a
transplant that is the temporary
placement of a uterus inside of the body
so that a person can experience some of
the normal processes that go along with
pregnancy but that uterus is then going
to be taken out after the pregnancy is
over it is the temporary placement of a
uterus into
a woman which is not a transplant I've
never heard of a transplant before
that's temporary maybe there are
examples but I would argue that that's
that actually deserves a different term
um that's a that's a a temporary thing
and there is a question I mean look I
certainly have sympathy for a woman who
can't give birth because of a
compromised or absent
uterus on the other hand there is a
question about something do you really
in order to have the natural experience
of pregnancy rather than for example
adopting a child
um
this is a very highly medicalized and
unnatural process it sure is yeah no and
I um I wish I knew the answer to your
question but I assume that it's just
going to be safe now that I've heard
what I've heard I would bet uh and
dollars to Donuts you know there are a
lot of C-section babies out there um and
and cesarean sections have um you know
have saved the lives of countless
mothers and babies
um but it's not as good as vaginal birth
it's just not right um it doesn't impart
the same
um information
um largely immune uh that vaginal birth
does
um and that's that's just one of the
things that we can see uh that is going
to be difficult here and of course all
of this assumes that everything else
about the the woman the mother to be
into whom the uterus is being
transplanted is functional and that she
has all of the other systems um that
that are necessary right so just one
more
um brief
thing from the discussion section of
this paper 2017 on the status of uterine
transplants in humans uterine
transplantation is a temporary process
in which the recipient undergoes a
process of adapting to a received uterus
followed by treatments to achieve
pregnancy through IVF which ultimately
bring a child into the world in the
shortest time possible to allow the
removal of the uterus
the recipient has to go through a
process that brings with it a new phase
of understanding pain over the loss and
re-adaptation so there's an additional
you know much as women who have had
hysterectomies
um
often and you know I've I've spoken to
some I know I know some have experienced
great loss even those who felt that they
were already beyond their child bearing
years you know giving up some part of
your body especially if it is associated
with a particular you know way of being
that you that you know has contributed
to how you are in the world
can provide a significant kind of loss
and if if you have been able to receive
an organ that you have then just hated a
child in and that child is now in the
world and is going to be your child
forever and then you have to give up the
organ that that allowed it that is gonna
that is going to take as they say a new
phase of understanding pain over the
loss and re-adaptation and you know all
sorts of unintended consequences as a
result of this technology right so on
the same topic
the it's very seems very unlike I mean
humans are unique in the sense of having
or almost unique in the sense of having
menopause where you have these organs
which are sidelined after some uh stage
of life
because humans are almost unique in
having this and it's really a couple of
other creatures in which they're
candidates I think elephants and orcas
but
the idea that this tissue remains there
inert is not resorbed
likely that tissue is still doing things
and the question of what is
endocrinological impact is and therefore
what the loss of it is and what impacts
that has are significant now person who
doesn't have a uterus or had to have it
removed because of a pathology
would be in that circumstance anyway but
one does have to ask the question let's
say that you temper using the term
maybe I should not use the term install
you implant a uterus
um in a woman who doesn't have one
if she is then presumably a egg is then
implanted a fertilized egg is implanted
an embryo is implanted the pregnancy
proceeds a cesarean section happens the
uterus is removed
my guess is that this is not going to
trigger normal lactation either
that would be my guess and that that's
one I don't know
I'm not certain of that okay I um
yeah there's so there's so many of
course
just to think endocrinologically which
is not all of it but there's so many
hormonal
triggers and associations with pregnancy
and you know just just the things I'm
thinking of at the moment other than the
estrogens and progesterone but prolactin
and
um and oxytocin and gosh others
luteinizing hormone and they just a lot
of these things I don't
the
I also don't know anything about what
prompts
birth like you know are you do uterine
contractions prompt a C-section here and
one one of the reasons I think that
C-sections aren't
um
as beneficial to babies as vaginal birth
is that what leads up to vaginal birth
is the body preparing to have a baby
that needs to be fed outside of the body
as opposed to inside the body and so
there is a certain you know the letdown
of milk and you know all of these things
that happen are triggered from inside
the body and you know a C-section just
like adds also like a scheduled vaginal
delivery won't tend to be
um the body will not tend to be as
prepared as it would be if um if the
body was in charge as opposed to a
doctor yeah I I agree with that and so I
will just I predict that this doesn't
result in normal lactation there's also
a question about the things like
antibiotics and other compounds that
will be used to make these two surgeries
that are you know bookending pregnancy
um to make that work there's a question
about whether or not that stuff ends up
in the breast milk if there even is
breast milk so I again my overall
impression is
I have the I mean I again lots of
sympathy for women who find themselves
reproductively incapable for whatever
reason but that this sounds like yes
there are people who are so desperate to
have gone through pregnancy that they
will do virtually anything and so the
demand here is very high that does not
make this wise and it this is so highly
technological and medical that the idea
that it is done so that you can have the
natural experience of pregnancy
how natural is that
okay
there's more
how about uterine transplants for trans
women
I was afraid you were headed there
um first
definitions
I increasingly I do not like the term
trans woman and trans men
because
um while it seemed a kindness and a kind
of respect it of course has been
weaponized and now you have all sorts of
people saying it's type of woman just
type woman well no no it's not so I just
Googled duckduckgoed
um trans women definition just to see
and yeah
and so what I have
um just from the American Heritage
dictionary
is trans woman noun one a transgender
person who lives as a woman
I would say transgender man who lives as
a woman but yeah okay
or it's second definition of male to
female transgender or transsexual person
okay good Wikipedia however
I remember Wikipedia yes Wikipedia a
trans woman is a woman who was assigned
male at Birth trans women have a female
gender identity and may experience
gender dysphoria
General dysphoria may be treated with
gender firm and Care gender affirming
care may include social and medical
transition
do you remember when Wikipedia was good
oh man that was great so that's insane
Wikipedia is wrong that's not what a
trans woman is but that's what we are
being led to believe and that's what
something like half the country is at
least pretending to believe uh when they
say trans women okay so that is what I
mean now when I am saying what about
uterine transplants
for trans women that's men
who are living as women
should they be allowed to get uterine
transplants
yes you have to comment well no is the
answer
um and no is the answer because children
have to be Primary in all of this and
there is no way that the Brave New World
represented by
um
I mean effectively you are
transplanting
a
uterus you are using a trans woman that
is a man living as a woman
you are using that person's
blood to keep alive a uterus from
somebody else
that
um
the the thing is so there's nothing
natural about this okay well the
American medical association's journal
of Ethics feels differently
the American Medical Association okay
here we go yeah June 2023 hey the same
yeah the same month
uh the New England Journal of Medicine
published that important research albeit
untethered to any theoretical
considerations that we talked about in
the first half of today's episode here
it is the AMA American medical
association's journal of Ethics in June
published what it identifies right up
front is a peer-reviewed article
called should uterus transplantation for
trans women and trans men
be subsidized
here we go
from the introduction
costs of uterus transplantation
gestation of a child following uterus
transplantation and cisgender women with
absolute uterine infertility Factor has
proved successful in the United States
the reference that they give there
incidentally is the paper that I was
just reading from so that is a weak
version of successful but let's take
that at face value for the moment
given the success of uterine
transplantation that relies on both
living and deceased donors not at the
same time they're talking about
different situations but okay
um
interest in the procedure is likely to
extend beyond cisgender women
among those likely to be interested in
urine transplants are trans women who
want to gestate their own children
trans women who want uterus transplants
to consolidate their identities but not
to gestate children
some trans men who want to gestate their
own children and CIS men wanting to
gestate Children of Their Own
I will continue
so that you can have time this was
published
two months ago not April all right yeah
with regard to trans women who want to
gestate children
even though there has been no uterus
transplant to date in trans women that
we know of some clinicians have
maintained that there are no absolute
barriers in anatomy hormones and
obstetric considerations so would rule
out the possibility of successful urine
transplant and trans women
trans women wanting to gestate children
can plausibly justify subsidy of uterine
transplants on a number of crowns as
mentioned above
trans women lack a trait the ability to
Bear children that may cause them to
experience psychological dissonance in a
way that undermines their health and
well-being
the lack of uterus also closes off the
prospect of gestating a child in a way
that is available to women as a class
it follows the lack of uterus is an
obstacle to full participation in the
social goods attached to women's
identity
so too is the fact that you're not a
woman
that's going to get in the way of
participating in Womanhood
it just is
I'm going to read that one sentence that
struck me a lot and then I'm go on a
little bit and then
trans women lack a trait
the ability to Bear children that may
cause them to experience psychological
dissonance in a way that undermines
their health and well-being and the next
sentence is particularly Massachusetts
the lack of a uterus also closes off the
prospect of just hitting a child in a
way that is available to women as a
class
so
one thing that emerges from this one of
many things that emerges from this is
that
people need to stop looking to Medical
intervention to solve their socio
psychological problems
get a
doesn't get a grip
outside do something real learn a skill
eat real food move your body anything
get a grip not a uterus this is insane
okay trans women who want to consolidate
identity so this is an article in the
American medical association's journal
of ethics on why insurance companies
should consider paying for uterine
transplants in all sorts of people who
aren't actually women including CIS men
who are women but the re well we'll get
there but oh my God okay trans women who
want to consolidate identity some but
not all of this rationale also applies
to trans women who want uterine
transplants not to have a child but to
consolidate their identity they may
experience dissonance and not having a
uterus but in this case uterine
transplant is not sought to remedy lack
of access to the goods the goods of
gestation and childbearing I will remind
the viewers and the listeners that this
is inherently a temporary process it is
removed after parity is achieved after
birth happens because it's not a
long-term sustainable solution to
anything because of the
immunosuppressive drugs you have to be
on as a result of having someone else's
uterus in your body
um
I would point out that there are two
other issues here oh there are so many
other issues but uh okay okay no you
yeah before we get to the trans men yes
go on
well I just wanna I just want to point
out
these
uteri
sure
come from somewhere
they are either going to come from
actual women and of course this is a
document about the ethics of this
process and so some of them are coming
from
trans men who have decided they don't
need their uterine anymore
in fact I have to get rid of it in order
to fully realize they're whatever they
said yeah
um yeah okay well let's put it this way
but it's also there's also um cadaver
donors well cadaver donors but it
sounded like from the first paper that
you read that that was not as likely to
function
um the cases
um there have been successful cases
um yeah but from not cadaver from the
two successful cases that I can think of
that I know in my head were actually
living mother to daughter yeah and I
think another one was another family
member okay but I mean but in the case
of a
so-called trans woman
are we going to get into a situation
where women are going to be paid to
surrender their uteruses and therefore
if uteruses are important to being a
woman some woman is giving up some
amount of womanness in order for some
guy to pretend to be a woman yeah you
thought surrogacy was bad right this is
this is next level insane then we're
gonna get into okay suppose
that these are going to be cadaver
uteruses can you become a donor that
forbids the installing of your uterus
into a trans woman transphobic exactly
and so the point is then there's going
to be some legal question about whether
or not you are allowed to be specific
about to whom your organs go and
presumably you can't and so this is
going to cause organ donation to dry up
yep I mean sure the whole thing is so
Bonkers and over it's not like
you know it masquerades as a magic wand
that's going to allow you to experience
this sacred piece of being a woman and
the point is no this is so heavily
medicalized that there's nothing natural
about it
even works for real women exactly
okay one more bit from this paper
with regard to Who besides women might
be um
might be eligible for uterine
transplants
trans men who want to gestate children
after gender affirming surgery
so before I read the rest of this let me
just unpack
yeah please do because I'm working
I can't get it this is women
who've decided they're actually men
and who have had
so-called bottom surgery
that removes their functional female
reproductive parts and maybe install
some totally non-functional mail Parts
out of the skin on their arm whatever
um having thought about it more
decided that yeah they still apparently
buy this uh by this language do believe
themselves to be men that is trans men
but they also want to gestate a child
because that's what men do
trans men who want to gestate children
after gender affirming surgery
this is not detransitioners right this
is trans men who want to gestate
children after gender affirming surgery
trans Men start life with female typical
bodies but modify their bodies to align
with male typical traits to varying
degrees
some trans men have children prior to
any body modifications that interfere
with gestation
others do not and have their uterus
removed to conform their bodies to a
certain gender ideal
some trans men have transitioned in
gender but retain their uterus and
gestated children
this precedent triggered interest in
uterine transplants among trans men
especially if they did not retain their
uterus or store gametes prior to their
transition
what is the word
what is any of this doing here
this is so Beyond uh
like simultaneously narcissistic at the
individual level and apocalyptic at the
societal level it is it is a apocalyptic
narcissism may have my screen back for a
second
um
it's even worse than that whoa yeah
um do you have comments before I go even
worse than that yeah there's something
about this that is I increasingly regard
transhumanism as
a kind of
techno-utopian mental disorder yep 100
and the point is you one of the
principles of maturation one of the
things that you are supposed to pick up
as you become a human being I mean let's
face it you are getting used to all
sorts of craziness to be a human being
yes you are a fish who has taken to land
and you your ancestors spent a lot of
time as a primate swinging through the
trees right so you have this weird set
of baggage and then okay you're a person
and you're a person and you can use
language to convey things or to
manipulate or you have all of the things
that language does
part of becoming a person is reconciling
yourself to what you are and playing the
hand you've been dealt if you don't like
that hand you can work to better
yourself to upgrade it but the idea of
dragging medicine into tailoring you or
tailoring you enough that at a cocktail
party you can claim to be something and
there is some medical justification for
using the terms you're using it's
nonsense you how much happier are people
who do this actually going to be how
much worse I mean
of course plastic surgery is the same
thing right yeah and you know bigger
boobs tighter jawline skin light I mean
Michael Jackson was you know was doing
this constantly as well in you know in a
different domain
and okay you look like your version of a
more perfect ideal
and now what like now you know that you
couldn't get there on your own like to
what end right to what end and and the
fact is if you are look we have a world
that's badly structured developmentally
it's a mess and it causes lots and lots
of people to be deeply dissatisfied
which is not their fault that is the
fault of us having structured the world
that they were born into badly and we
should fix it but if you are such a
person you are born into this crazy
world and development leaves you totally
unsatisfied with what you are so you
want a total redo what are the chances
that the redo that you
get the medical establishment to provide
you for money is actually going to
satisfy you what what is the chances
that the problem isn't that you are
constitutionally unsatisfied and
unsatisfiable and that you're going to
be as unsatisfied with the thing you
land as as the thing you started off as
the chances are extremely high so why
is modern medicine
uh pretending that that's not even a
question oh you think you'll be happier
when you have X how many myths do we
have in which people
do we not have a proverb be careful what
you wish for right people used to know
that you needed to be careful what you
wished for because you might not be as
happy with it if you got it as you think
you will be that's a Grass Is Always
Greener The Grass Is Always Greener that
whole thing and so somebody at the very
least needs to study this madness and
discover whether or not it results in
satisfied people or people who
get to these places compromised in uh in
themselves and still feel about as they
did which that's the cruel trick that's
being played on kids kids are being told
hey that thing that you desperately want
you can have it and then of course the
kid is going to learn after they've lost
their reproductive capacity
their ability to have a proper sex life
they're going to discover oh that was a
lie told to you by adults who should
have known better but there was money at
stake yeah it didn't know better usually
okay so you know how um
luckily we have never been
um in these fields but you know how a
lot of professional Fields require for
you to stay in good standing that you
get continuing education credits
uh so if you go back and look at this
paper that I've just been reading from
the American Medical Association Journal
of Ethics right below the abstract it
says the American Medical Association
designates this journal-based CME
activity for a maximum of one AMA pra
category 1 Credit available to AMA Ed
hub Physicians should claim only the
credit commensurate with the extent of
their participation in the activity I
looked at that went that's a lot of
acronyms they don't recognize but I
suspect and it turns out I was right
that what that's referring to is the
American Medical association's pra
credit system which demonstrates a
physician has participated in continuing
medical education activities that meet
the requirements of State Medical boards
medical specialty societies specialty
boards Hospital medical staffs The Joint
Commission Insurance Groups and others
and there is a quiz that you can take
based on this article that I've just
been reading to you and if you pass you
get some continuing medical credits from
the AMA now I took this quiz and I
passed it but I'm going to show you the
first of five and you only have to get
four of these questions right
the first of five questions in this quiz
just to demonstrate what it is that you
need to stay in good standing with for
instance your State Medical Board your
medical specialty Society your specialty
boards your Hospital medical staffs your
insurance companies Etc okay hand me my
screen for a second so I can find it
here Zach
um
I told you it was even worse than that
uh okay hold on let me find this okay so
yeah here we are uh you can show uh this
is uh this is the continuing medical
education version of this article they
have in case the article was just too
complex for you they've supplied a an
outline
and then you can actually take the quiz
and uh you know they have author of
author affiliations over here and again
the the title of the article that you
can demonstrate your complete knowledge
of in order to get um consuming medical
medical education credits through the
AMA is should uterus transplantation for
trans women and trans men be subsidized
the first question of five on the quiz
is which of the following is true about
uterus transplantation in trans women
Anatomy serves as a barrier to doing so
a b hormones make uterus transplantation
and trans women impossible
C obstetric considerations have produced
poor results
d
no uterus transplant has been performed
in a trans woman
obviously
at least one correct answer to this
question is a
Anatomy serves as a barrier to doing so
I however long skilled in taking tests
and gaming such systems knew exactly
what they were looking for because it is
also true that D no uterus transplant
has been performed in a trans woman
and that is of course the only correct
answer that they will accept for this
quiz which you would be very well aware
of if you would read the outline
um
considerately provided by the AMA in
order for you to gain as a physician
your continuing medical education
credits and one more time my screen uh
if I might just want to just want to
show off that I did indeed pass here we
go
um this you can show this this certifies
that I successfully completely completed
this journal-based continuing medical
education activity should uterus
transplantation for trans women and
trans men be subsidized if I had a State
Medical Board or insurance company or
anything that I needed to report my
continuing medical education credits to
I could use this to demonstrate that I
am in full current standing and I have
been keeping up on my medical education
and I really know what's going on now so
you could trust me patience with
everything you need because I have
passed this quiz
well you weren't kidding about it's
worse than that that is
unbelievable that I mean it is obviously
a medical version of the social
credit score method for controlling
Behavior
I can't even figure out how you phrase
the
obvious indoctrination of doctors so
that they are on board with things that
are clearly a violation of
um the Hippocratic oath and almost
certainly in practice Nuremberg
to be fair why should we but to be fair
I see I don't know how many ways that
you can earn your continuing medical
medical education credits right sure so
like there's there's I do not suspect
that most doctors
are are being funneled through this
particular thing it doesn't make any
difference it doesn't make any
difference what they are doing is they
are causing
a belief system that is radical and
highly suspect to become commonplace by
teaching it as if it were factual and
then testing you on it for a credit that
you need in which you have to answer the
wrong way in order to pass you have to
deny what was the question again you
have to deny that there's uh Anatomy
serves as a barrier to uterus
transplantation for men
to happen to think they're women right
you have to not notice that that is an
obviously correct answer and how many
times do you say lies before you start
to believe them well that's just the
thing and so
here is at least one of the punch lines
of
it's worse than that in this case yeah
how did we get to a place where
virtually the entirety of modern
medicine the medical schools the
hospitals
the doctors the nurses were all saying
false things about the safety and
effectiveness of treatments well this is
the system they live in right and that
system in that system this is not going
to strike people as wildly Beyond The
Pale right this is somehow normal and it
creates why are we so obsessed with this
why do we care I don't care so much this
is also of a piece with when we covered
um
uh McNeil and Fentons
a collection of the jumping of the stats
yeah the Cheap Trick In which
um efficacy was simulated through a
mathematical a statistical artifact
coveted vaccine efficacy was simulated
through a experimental design artifact
right in paper after paper that had been
peer-reviewed and nobody caught it and
our point was actually peer-reviewed
clearly doesn't exist because if it
didn't catch this then it couldn't have
caught anything what's it catcher right
so the point is okay that's the academic
side this is the medical side you have
Pure medical nonsense being taught and
then tested as if it were factually
insightful and a required bit of
knowledge in order to practice
this is madness yes you absolutely do
not want a doctor the only doctor who
passed that test that you want is one
who knew they were lying in order to
pass it who knew they were gaming the
system any doctor who thought that they
were actually participating in
continuing education and responded
correctly is not a doctor that you want
dealing with your medical issues that's
right so that's the world we're living
in and what it means is you want the
only things that make any sense are
going to be off label
you want the things that were reviewed
by peers in a bar
gave you a hard time about stuff in your
study and got you to fix it in a bar you
don't want it peer-reviewed at some
Journal that believes nonsense that's
not going to work it's going to be
counterproductive you don't want doctors
who went through continuing education in
silliness like this you want doctors who
care enough about it I mean I think I
think the bar thing is actually
important here you know it doesn't need
to be a bar but you want people who care
deeply enough about the scientific
process and about medicine and about
what it is that they've chosen to
dedicate their lives to that they
continue to talk about it when they're
not literally being paid to do so right
that this is this is in their minds this
is like you know you are you a scientist
after 5 PM well yes right so you know
those of us who think this way it is it
is a way of being it is not something
that stops at the office door and the
paycheck and you know I think peer
review has become just like these
continuing medical uh education credits
just like well I just got tick the Box
tick the Box okay what do I have to do
today I'm gonna pick up milk at the
grocery store I gotta get my CMEs I got
like it's meaningless and it's just one
more thing and a list of meaningless
events that everyone is doing and like
to the degree that some number of
doctors had real passion and and
compassion when they began their work
this will kill it
this this will This Will Destroy it it
will destroy it yeah I I'm reminded I
can't remember the name of the guy but
there was a registered nurse during
early in covid who was reporting that
patients that he
was in charge of he knew very well that
the treatment they were being being
given required that they'd be gotten up
and out of bed and walked around
um because they were going to drown in
their own fluids if they were left
sitting and they were forbidden to do it
and I remember him saying
I cannot participate in this anymore I
cannot be in charge of these patients
where I know the right thing to do for
them and I'm not allowed to do it and I
have to watch them die
and he quit and I think the point is
okay what role does that leave us where
the people who didn't quit are the last
people you would want in charge of your
care but it's all you're going to have
available to you and there there has to
be some sort of you know you now have
I guess we're the off-label scientists
oh yeah you know we'll review papers
right here on Dark Horse right is that
peer review well I don't know if you're
up to it I guess it is but you know
you don't want something that's been
reviewed by people who didn't spot the
Cheap Trick right right those people are
not qualified whatever their their
degree says yep and doctors who pass a
test like this and didn't know that they
were lying in order to pass it yeah
aren't doctors that you want in charge
of your your health that's insane nope
that's
that's all true that's all true so
um sorry to have blown your mind like
that yeah you know it did actually throw
me because you think you know how
ridiculous things get and the fact is
okay uterine transplants if you think
about it of course should such a thing
be medically possible then of course it
would be dragged into this this trans
Madness
um but the idea of the AMA this isn't
some Fringe practice this is the AMA
signing on to it wholesale and then
creating quizzes and continuing medical
education as a way to what fund
themselves
as a way to justify their continued
existence yeah all right so it you uh
you did succeed in uh putting me back on
my heels where I I thought I was pretty
verse pretty well versed in this space
that I did not see the the AMA leading
the charge here yeah
uh well there it is
uh more than halfway through 2023 who
knows what comes next or whether we get
to the end of 2023 oh I hope so
I hope we do I hope we do
um I think that about does it
that about does it all right I think
that if that does it but we will be back
uh so we are going to uh spend a couple
minutes telling you about places to find
us some things to look for and such but
we will be back about 15 minutes after
we stop with our live q a uh where you
can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com and
um let's see we've got lots of things to
talk about uh please uh subscribe to the
channel on Rumble and please consider
joining us at locals so at locals you
get the watch parties uh with our live
streams you get all the guest episodes
and Brett's doing a lot of them now
they're they're two three four a month
at this point and when they are released
they're released on locals a day before
they're released anywhere else to our
locals Community only on Saturdays and
then a day later
our local supporters thank you Zach our
local supporters on Saturday and then a
day later to to rumble on Spotify and
YouTube and everywhere else
uh and uh we also this month are going
to start doing our private q a instead
of at my patreon we're going to be doing
that for our supporters on locals and
the Discord integration is going to be
up and running before the end of the
month hopefully
maybe okay
um
oh we are we're working on that
um let's see oh at Natural Selections
this week I wrote about a near miss that
I had with a truck I was on my bicycle
it was a pickup truck and I wrote about
rules of the road and um what it is to
be an experienced bicyclist on the road
sharing um sharing the road with drivers
most of whom haven't spent time on bikes
but also talked about a theory of mind
and
um and and a bit about and I didn't
specify this in the piece but
um you and I went back to that same
place later that day we were driving
into town and I asked you to drive us
back through that from the opposite
direction and we went a couple of times
because it struck me that
um
in this place where I had been following
all of the rules and and because I am a
skilled bicyclist I did not get
flattened by a truck that turned in
front of me as it should not have
um coming up from the other direction in
a truck as we were I saw that the
visibility uh was not as good as I
thought it was and so uh I I too did not
have as complete a model of ethereum
Mind of the driver there as I should
have not you know again
she was in the wrong and and I was not
but
who's in the wrong who's in the right
isn't a complete description of how it
is that you have to be maneuvering
around spaces right you also have to
really really try to put yourself in the
head of other people and not just what
they know which is where I spent a lot
of the piece like okay most drivers
don't know how to bike they don't never
bike with you know they've never biked
on roads really
um but even more important and really
more human and more basic is what can
they see like what could what can they
actually see what do they what do they
know about the experience of the
environment that is different from what
you see and you know as anyone who's
ever hiked knows especially if you've
gone to the backcountry and you've known
that you need to sort of keep checking
back so that you know what things look
like in both directions you can be in a
particular spot looking this way and
things look totally different if you
just turn 180 degrees right and so the
same is true when you're uh when you're
in traffic
um so check that out that's rules of the
road at Natural Selections this week
uh we've got stuff at the store we're
gonna we're gonna have some new stuff at
the store soon you just proposed a new
new piece of merchandise but we've got
uh we've got Dark Horse merch sign up
until proven otherwise epic Tabby lots
of good stuff there uh we've got a book
we've still got our patreons we got
these fantastic monthly meetings
um that you're running on yours
um
yeah and and the Discord server which is
currently at our patreons are going to
be moving it into the Discord uh into
locals as soon as we can
um lots of great conversation there so
we encourage you to join us there as
well
our wonderful sponsors this week again
we're mind Bloom Sundays and paleo
Valley check them out
and we're supported by you we thank you
uh please subscribe share like
uh and uh and and talk with people about
what you're hearing here and about where
you too can pick up your continuing
medical education credits if you need
them
it's easy like it's it's not hard at all
you can you can do that without any
effort at all
continuing medical indoctrination credit
yeah they don't put that eye in there
but it belongs in there yeah okay so
again we'll be back in in a bit uh with
the Q a and then I'll of course we'll be
back next week same time Wednesdays at
11 30 Pacific with another live stream
until we see you next be good to the
ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
[Music]